(classical music)
(speaking Chinese)
(fast-paced music)
- [Narrator] This Great Big
Story was made possible by
Raffles, Hotels & Resorts.
(classical music)
- [Narrator] In the city
of Chengdu, in the Chinese province
of Sichuan, you'll find a
curious cultural combination:
a butler school where East meets West.
(speaking Chinese)
A big catalyst for the school
was actually a gentleman
who goes by the name of Mr. Carson.
(speaking Chinese)
With that, demand for these
highly-skilled butlers rose.
To train them, Karen runs
an intense six-week program.
(speaking Chinese)
(gentle harp music)
(soft clicking)
(bubbles popping)
(speaking Chinese)
(tinny rattle)
(popping)